hey guys Pete here today I'm going to
talk about a location we've seen before
in a game of Thrones but it is also
looking to play a big part in season 7
this will be my history of Dragonstone
video and I'll be talking about dragon
stones importance plus some of the
things that have happened there in the
past I won't go into any of the spoilers
from the season 7 filming we've seen you
can watch my other videos for that but
this will contain spoilers for
everything that's happened in the series
through season 6 also we've hit 18,000
subscribers so at the end I will
announce the winner of the book giveaway
so that you can send me your address and
I can send you out your book if you
subscribed and commented on any of the
giveaway videos make sure you stick
around until the end also I'm recording
this video from a hotel in downtown
Poonam Penh so the background noise
there's a little bit construction next
door so there might be some more
background noise than usual so I
apologize in advance now let's get into
this bit of history dragon stone is a
castle located on the island of the same
name at the entrance to Blackwater Bay
located below the dragon montt and
shaped from stone to look like dragons
dragon stone was the original seat of
House Targaryen in Westeros and had been
colonized and fortified as the
westernmost outpost of the Valyrian
freehold after Aegon's conquest of the
Seven Kingdoms dragon stone in the newly
created crown lands served as the seat
of the heir apparent known as the Prince
of Dragonstone after Robert Baratheon
overthrew the Targaryen and Robert's
rebellion he gave the castle to his
brother Stannis creating house Baratheon
of Dragonstone the castle though old and
strong commands the allegiance of only a
few lesser Lords whose islands are too
thinly populated to provide any great
number of troops although they do have
some naval strength Dragonstone is a
unique castle that is more Valyrian than
Westeros II it was built using advanced
Valyrian techniques of masonry that were
lost during the do this may have
involved dragon fire since the Targaryen
were possession of the West only dragons
at the time the Citadel of dragon stone
is made of shaped black stone which some
hotels referred to as the stones of hell
and his towers are carved into the
shapes of dragons along the three
curtain walls it's decorated with
asking gargoyles and the images of
demons Griffins hellhounds manticores
Minotaur minotaurs and other creatures
the design of the castle is very dragon
oriented small dragons frame gates and
dragon claws hold torches a pair of
great wings cover the armory and smithy
and Tails frame archways and staircases
the stone drum is the central keep of
dragon stone named as such because of
the booming sound made by the powerful
wind storing storms cells in the
dungeons beneath the Citadel are warmer
than they ought to be but as dank as one
might expect and sit you know on an
island such as dragon stone it is said
that there are shafts and secret stairs
leading further below into the heart of
the dragon lock the stone drum is
connected to the dungeon Tower by a high
stone bridge that arches over emptiness
the chamber of the painted table located
at the top floor of the stone drum is a
round room with with four tall windows
overlooking the north south east and
west it holds a large table carved and
painted in the form of a detailed map of
Westeros here Aegon the conquerer
planned for the invasion of Westeros
show Watchers are familiar with this
chamber since most of the dragon stone
scenes we had with Stannis took place
here the painted table is pretty long
and wide it gets an arrow it's shaped
like a map at the brick at the precise
location of Dragonstone is a raised seat
that allows the occupant to view the
entire match map which is pretty cool
the Great Hall is carved in the shape of
a huge dragon lying on its belly its
doors are set in the mouth and those
entering pass through the mouth the
kitchens resemble a curled up dragon
where the smoke and heat vented through
its nostrils Aegon's garden is a garden
near the arch of the Dragons tail within
its confines grow tall trees on every
side as well as wild roses when worm is
one of the towers of Dragonstone it's
shaped like a dragon that arches into
the sky screaming defiantly sea dragon
tower you guessed it is shaped like a
dragon to this time though it's at peace
facing the sea the maesters chamber lies
in this tower below the Rookery the Sept
is kind of needed it contains carved
statues of the Seven aspects of the
faith of the seventh god they're pretty
ornate and there's things like the Crone
has paralyzed the father a gilded beard
Ranger looks more animal than human
they've been carved from the mass of the
ships that carried the first Targaryen
to dragonstone and many layers of paint
and varnish had been applied to them
over the centuries there were several
altars there that were you know they had
some stained glass and it said that
Aegon the conquerer knelt to pray in
Dragonstone set the night before he
sailed to conquer the Seven Kingdoms
this is a little bit questionable though
as Aegon only publicly converted when he
reached old town during his invasion the
Sept could have been constructed after
the fact just my own speculation I think
that's probably true
the Valerians were known to have several
different gods like balerion veigar see
racks and MARAC seas which also there
are dragons named after them later it
seemed they regarded all faiths to be
equally false and in valaria itself the
clergy and temples were looked down upon
as relics of primitive times but they
were useful to placate the lower classes
with promises of a better life to come
after death so they promoted religious
tolerance which they knew kept their
subjects divided this also prevented
them from unifying under the banner of a
single God so they don't really sound
very pious and it doesn't seem that
likely to me that Aegon would have just
found religion in his time there so why
is Dragonstone important for a Targaryen
like Daenerys who had also been born
there it's important because this is
where Aegon's conquest started it's also
important in relation to old deliria
because of the doom before the doom
Valyrian took possession of the island
which became the westernmost
outpost of the blaring freehold they
built the castle using their magic to
make the towers look like dragons and
that's where the name came from so
basically they build a spooky-looking
castle right next door to their
unconquered neighbors which reminded
them that hey we have dragons over here
12 years before the doom actually
happened a Targaryen named aina
relocated his whole family there are
five dragons and all their wealth to
Dragonstone he did this based on visions
his daughter
Danis had in dreams she became known as
Dainius the dreamer because these
visions not only saved her family from
the Dune but also saved their dragons
which ended up being the only ones that
survived the catechol
that the doom was in valaria the
Tarkan's weren't anything special they
were Dragon Lord sure but at that time
there were around 40 families with
dragons many of which had more wealth
and more power than them the doom
changed all this though and aina and his
family found themselves on Dragonstone
as the only Dragon Lord family left
standing
I went over most of this in my kin Jon
Snow ride a dragon video so you should
check that out if you want a better
history of dragons coming to Westeros
the early Targaryen is on Dragonstone
started with five dragons but for them
eventually died there they hatched two
eggs in that time though bringing the
total to three they married brother to
sister primarily to keep the Valyrian
blood pure and within a few generations
Aegon the conquerer was born he took his
two sisters as his wives and they set
out to conquer Westeros with their three
dragons
he was the last Lord of Dragonstone and
the first king of the Seven Kingdoms
Aegon first made landfall at the mouth
of the Blackwater rush and established a
new seat called the Aegon for the city
of King's Landing grew up around that
later the Aegon fort was tore down and
replaced by the red key King's Landing
became the capital of the Seven Kingdoms
and Dragonstone became the seat of the
heir apparent to the Iron Throne who was
thereafter known as the prince or
princess of Dragonstone so by now you
can hopefully see some parallels with
the first Targaryen invasion of Westeros
and the advance west of Queen Daenerys
that we saw starting at the end of
season six the location of Dragonstone
is important now as it was then and it
makes for a good place to start
considering its previous occupants
Stannis Baratheon just got himself
killed Waring up in the north if you're
wondering how Stannis ended up there
it's worth mentioning during the War of
the server or Robert's rebellion Robert
Baratheon killed the Prince of
Dragonstone Rhaegar Targaryen at the
Battle of the Trident when this news
made its way to King's Landing King
Aerys sent his pregnant sister wife
Queen rhaella
and his only surviving child Prince
Viserys to Dragonstone Rey ala died
there giving birth to princess Daenerys
Targaryen during a raging summer storm
does she is sometimes called Daenerys
Stormborn the storm destroyed the rest
of the
targaryen fleet and with the Queen dying
there and all the remaining Targaryen
xand Kings Landing dying the War of the
usurper basically ended of course
viserys and danerys were smuggled away
before they were captured when Robert
took the Iron Throne he gave Dragonstone
to his brother Stannis who became the
new Lord of Dragonstone Stannis resented
this castle because its lands were far
poorer than those of storms and which he
felt was his due to the fact that he was
the heir to house Baratheon
but King Robert the first had granted
that castle to their younger brother
Renly Robert said he felt a strong
leader should be placed in the old
Targaryen seat and its occupants was
traditionally the heir to the Iron
Throne however Robert was also pissed
off because the Targaryen children had
escaped to Essos and Stannis considered
getting Dragonstone to be an insult
there's a lot more but I think this
gives you a good idea of some of the
reasons why Dragonstone is an important
place Aegon Rhaenys and Visenya launched
out from Dragonstone with their three
dragons to conquer Westeros 300 years
ago and now the last Targaryen to be
born there is headed to Westeros she has
three dragons and a horde of loyal
supporters coming from the east in hopes
to conquer Westeros once again if you
have any questions about Dragonstone or
the castle be sure to leave them for me
in the comments I try to get to as many
of them as I can please like the video
if you enjoyed it and make sure to
subscribe to my channel to find out
about my latest Game of Thrones videos
when as soon as they come out now for
the giveaway I've reached my goal of
18,000 subscribers so it's time to pick
a winner in the background you can see a
screen capture of the process I went
through to pick this person out I'll
explain it to you too so you guys know
that everything's on the up-and-up
but each of the videos that were
eligible in the giveaway into the random
comment picker one at a time
it basically scans all the the comments
and you can pick one out at random I
took the name it picked each time and
put it in a master list note my name
came up several times which it should
since I respond to so many comments you
guys leave in those cases I just hit to
pick the winner button again and it
picks another random comment after I had
one comment picked out from each video I
took that list and put them into the
random thing picker the list I generated
was from the oldest video to the newest
the
in the giveaway but it should have no
effect on the results since the random
thing picker is truly random so that
picked our winner and that in our winner
is undercover or ex undercover written
in sort of the hacker numbers and
letters I went to the I went to his
channel and was able to verify that he's
a subscriber so now the book is his or
hers I guess what you need to do
undercover is to go to my about page
there's an email listed there so you can
send me your contact details and I'll
send the copy of a night of Seven
Kingdoms your way congratulations and
thanks to everyone else who participated
in the giveaway I'm planning on starting
a new one in the next couple of days so
subscribe now and check back for details
on that one more time congratulations to
ex undercover you're the winner so get
in touch with me soon so we can wrap
things up thanks for watching you guys I
will talk to you soon